I'm a big football fan I love football
football is fun
unless you have an alcoholic friend who
roots for a shitty team like the Browns
you know what I'm talking about those
guys are the worst you know those people
I've been in their house before they
start getting [__] up and the Browns
do what they do every week they start
getting [__] up
and what's happening next that house is
I'm watching these videos of guys on
YouTube throw TVs off their balconies
what the [__] are you doing
like do you really think we would ever
encourage me to tear my house apart no
weed lays right next to me on the couch
Roots my favorite team's on
says [__] to me like hey Ryan you know
it'll be really nice around here
some holiday hand towels
oh hell yeah we
let's Spruce this place up a bit